en ma grève à l'école christian blacks
dans notre journal europe agricole pas
d'accord sur les prix
voilà monsieur bonsoir il y a quelques
années pour arriver à se mettre d'accord
les ministres de la communauté
européenne arrêtait la pendule et
négociaient jusqu'à ce qu'une solution
soit trouvée
eh bien cette fois ci les ministres de
l'agriculture ont eu beau discuter
jusqu'à 3 heures du matin cette nuit
n'ont trouvé aucune solution au problème
déprise agricole pour 1981 c'est très
grave car d'abord monsieur giscard
d'estaing voulait que ce problème soit
réglé avant le sommet des chefs d'état
européens dimanche à luxembourg puis
d'autre part cet échec provoque la
colère des agriculteurs français et
notamment de leur principal représentant
monsieur francois guillot président de
la fns a reçu cet après midi par
monsieur giscard d'estaing actuellement
notre inquiétude est grande dans la
mesure où l'absence de décision a des
conséquences sur le revenu des
agriculteurs et notamment des éleveurs
des producteurs de lait des producteurs
de viande
cette situation risque peut-être de
durée
en aucun cas les agriculteurs ne peuvent
en supporter les conséquences c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai indiqué au
président de la république que il
faudrait à ce moment-là examiner les
possibilités d'apporter des
compensations pour tout retard qui
serait pris dans la décision des prix ce
qui s'est passé cette nuit à bruxelles
est d'une importance capitale pour
l'europe
en gros deux points de vue prévalent et
par les discussions le point de vue
français tout d'abord qu'elles se sont
associées épisodiquement seulement il
faut le préciser
les irlandais et les belges les français
disent il faut se mettre tout de suite
d'accord sur la fixation des prix
agricoles et trouver la manière de
plonger les excédents laitiers
la deuxième le deuxième point de vue
c'est le point de vue des anglais hélas
tous les autres pays se sont associés
aux anglais y compris les allemands par
les anglais disent et c'est totalement
contradictoire avec la position
française
ils disent ne pas question de fixer les
prix agricoles tant que les neuf chefs
d'états et de gouvernements n'auront pas
examiné la contribution britannique au
marché commun pendant le sommet de
luxembourg qui aura lieu le 27 et 28
avril prochains
alors à ce dialogue de sourds pierre
méhaignerie lui fait des propositions il
a demandé à la commission qu'elle
propose des solutions pour arriver à
fixer ses prix agricoles la commission a
fait des propositions auxquelles les
neuf ministres agriculteurs n'ont pas
abouti pierre méhaignerie à 3 heures du
matin a refusé ces propositions parce
qu'il les a trouvés incomplète
plus qu'un échec je dirais surtout que
c'est une injustice et une incapacité
des ministres de l'agriculture ou de
certains ministres à prendre des
responsabilités politiques qui sont
leurs responsabilités non pas celle des
chefs d'état injustice vis-à-vis du
monde agricole
car il y a huit millions d'agriculteurs
qui ont besoin de sécurité comme les
autres catégories professionnelles qui
devrait avoir des prix fixée au 1er
avril
monsieur améliorée vous venez de le voir
était l'invité d'antenne de midi
aujourd'hui
ce sera donc au vu de ses résultats aux
chefs d'état de la communauté européenne
dimanche à bruxelles de à luxembourg
pardon de régler le problème
si la réunion a bien lieu malgré cet
échec l'ensemble des principaux
syndicats d'enseignants avaient décidé
pour aujourd'hui une grève pour
protester contre la politique du
gouvernement qui selon eux profitent
la baisse de la démographie en france
pour réduire les dépenses d'éducation le
point de cette journée jean-michel
nature en 48 heures de grève de la
maternelle à la terminale dans tous les
secteurs éducatif et à l'appel de
presque tous les syndicats si toutes les
écoles publiques de france n'était pas
fermée aujourd'hui
il y avait quand même selon les
syndicats 80 % de grévistes dans le
secondaire et jusqu'à 90 % dans le
primaire
une grève inégalement suivis selon lé
département répond le ministère de
l'éducation qui relève lui 70% de
grévistes parmi les instituteurs 50%
parmi les professeurs et 35 % parmi les
surveillants conclusions du ministère
une grève pas mieux suivie que les
précédentes
satisfaction en revanche du côté de la
fen pour qui l'opinion comprend et
appuie le mouvement des enseignants donc
un premier bilan contradictoire
à l'issue de ce premier jour le
mouvement des enseignants se poursuivra
demain par des manifestations à paris et
dans la plupart des grandes villes nous
vous l'annoncions dans les tic monsieur
black le ministre a dû qu'à sion est
notre invité ce soir en direct alors
monsieur le ministre je commencerai par
une question un peu naïve mais depuis
deux jours entre le premier ministre
monsieur bart qui a dit à l'assemblée
que les manifestations actuelles étaient
plus certainement d'origine politique
syndicale monsieur guy georges
secrétaire général du syndicat national
des instituteurs qui ne disait ce midi
que le gouvernement profité de la baisse
de la démographie pour réduire les
dépenses de l'éducation
et vous qui prétendez le contraire on a
vraiment l'impression que les uns et les
autres monsieur black
vous ne parlez pas de la même chose
volontairement ou involontairement mais
je crois d'abord que je suis un homme de
concertation vous le savez je suis même
conciliant mais je suis aussi un homme
de vérité
et quand monsieur guy georges dit que
nous voulons baisser les moyens il n'y a
qu'à regarder les chiffres du budget
c'est clair c'est net c'est officiel ça
a été voté
or le nombre des enseignants reste le
même à la rentrée 80
rentrée 79 c'est clair par conséquent
tout le reste ce sont des choses
inexactes ministre vous avez contre il
faut le reconnaître est aujourd'hui
cette journée l'a prouvé tous les
syndicats alors je ne parle pas des
parents d'élèves la fédération cornec
lance le mouvement pour samedi la
fédération lagarde refuse mais considère
que les enseignants de grands problèmes
alors est ce qu'on peut avoir raison
seul contre tous je crois que nous
sommes effectivement à un moment de
crise du système éducatif pendant trente
ans il y a eu une hausse démographique
il y a eu la scolarité obligatoire
jusqu'à 16 ans qui a multiplié par trois
et demi des effectifs dans les collèges
et par conséquent le système éducatif
avait comme problème numéro un
la création des postes et les syndicats
d'enseignants ont réclamé avec raison
des postes et les postes et puis
maintenant nous sommes dans une autre
situation
c'est à dire qu'il n'y a plus ces
grandes réformes puisque j'ai dit qu'il
n'y aurait pas de réformes lac et
d'autre part il y à une baisse
démographique qui tous les ans va nous
permettre d'avoir plusieurs milliers de
postes éventuellement libérables pour
améliorer la qualité et je les dis ceci
dès la fin de l'année 1978
par conséquent il n'ya plus à mettre en
priorité le problème des postes mais
alors comment expliquez-vous que vous
avez contre vous tous les syndicats
d'enseignants et pardonnez-moi des
syndicats qui ont des dix ont une
idéologie très différentes
alors toute cette unité contre vous
quand même elle et pas seulement sur une
bataille de chiffres n'en seront plus
importants non je crois que je viens de
vous dire il y a là un tournant
fondamental du système éducatif du père
maçon d'une période où on pouvait et on
devait réclamer toujours plus de postes
à une période où le gouvernement ayant
décidé malgré la baisse démographique
extraordinaire cinq cent mille enfants
de sueur dans les cinq ans qui viennent
permettent
grâce à cette baisse démographique en
décidant le maintien des moyens des
postes d'enseignants permettent ainsi
d'améliorer le système éducatif là où il
ya encore des problèmes car je ne nie
pas qu'il ya des problèmes dans
certaines classes qui restent encore
surchargé qu'il ya des problèmes de m
absents qu'il y a des problèmes de
d'amélioration dans des places où il ya
énormément d'immigrés par exemple nous
avons les moyens pour le faire à partir
du moment où le gouvernement maintient
les moyens alors je dis bien entendu il
y a là un changement complet de tonalité
et c'est pour ça que j'ai dit que
lorsque nos syndicats d'enseignants
reste sur le thème de postes et encore
des postes c'est un discours raciste car
la qualité maintenant et agger la
qualité c'est la formation des
enseignants
et nous savons tous qu'il vaut mieux
avoir un bon mètre formé avec 25 élèves
comme être moins bien moins bien formés
à laquelle avec va telle est bien il n'y
a pas que ce problème de qualité il y en
a bientôt monsieur min c'est une
question de parents d'élèves que je vais
vous poser là est-ce que puisque je vois
que vous restez sur vos positions que
les syndicats restent sur leurs
positions
alors est ce que nous parents d'élèves
nous allons vers une épreuve de force à
cause de ses positions qui reste très
dur de part et d'autre est ce qu'on va
pas vers de nouvelles grèves si rien ne
change si personne ne bouge
je ne crois pas que nous allions vers
tellement de nouvelles grèves
je crois qu'il est important que
l'ensemble du pays
parents d'élèves enseignants comprennent
que le gouvernement qui maintiennent des
moyens alors qu'il ya une baisse
démographique est le seul pays d'europe
qui agit ainsi
il suffit de voir ce qui se passe en
grande-bretagne en belgique en hollande
en allemagne
nous sommes le seul pays qui maintient
les moyens parce que nous continuons à
considérer que l'éducation est le budget
capitale de notre pays
alors lorsque les parents et des
enseignants à la suite de la crise que
nous vivons à l'heure actuelle et dont
je suis désolé croyez le bien
car je crois que ce n'est pas bon pour
nos enfants onze jours de travail en mai
26 jours entre avril et mai ce n'est pas
bon quand parents et enseignants
on comprit qu effectivement maintenant
les moyens nous gardons la priorité au
système éducatif etc avec cela nous
pouvons résoudre les problèmes tentative
qui demeurent et que les vrais problèmes
qualitative les vrais sont à hier je
crois à la générosité des enseignants je
crois au bon sens des syndicats pour que
nous puissions re parler des vrais
problèmes
merci monsieur black demain nous aurons
comme invité il pourra répondre aux
propos de monsieur black nous aurons
comme invité monsieur andré henry qui
est le secrétaire général de la
fédération de l'éducation nationale
cette grève dans l'enseignement
coïncider aujourd'hui avec la journée
nationale d'action décidé par la cgt qui
s'est concrétisée surtout dans le
secteur public par des arrêts de travail
et une manifestation à paris le bilan
isabelle bechr
la cgt s'est déclarée très satisfaite ce
soir du nombre de travailleurs qui ont
répondu à son appel à la grève et à la
manifestation aujourd'hui les militants
cgt ont été plusieurs dizaines de
milliers à défiler dans toute la france
pour le secteur privé le patronat parle
d'échec au cnps on assure que 5 à 10%
seulement le travailleurs ont répondu à
l'appel de leurs centrales nous en a
noté d exception de taille par exemple
70% de grévistes et les usines dassault
de martignas dans la gironde
les secteurs les plus perturbés auront
été la ratp à paris avec 86% de métro et
80% l'autobus en service ce qui n'est
pas catastrophique mais des coupures
sauvages d'électricité ont provoqué de
longues interruptions du réseau métro et
rer aux ptt le pourcentage de grévistes
avoisiner 11%
les débrayages de province étant moins
nombreux qu'à paris la distribution du
courrier ne devrait pas être dérangé
dans les jours qui agit d'une autre à
une grande journée de lutte des
travailleurs à travers tout le pays pour
exprimer leur volonté de voir réellement
changer une situation qui devient
insupportable aujourd'hui même on
annonce lundi sophie ciel du mois de
mars
et ça représente une nouvelle
augmentation de 1,2 pour cent d'après
l'insee c'est à dire que le pouvoir
d'achat se dégrade
ça devient inadmissible qu'on vient de
dire monsieur henri krasucki juste avant
moi 1,2 c'est le pourcentage de la
hausse des prix au mois de mars c'est la
troisième fois depuis le début de
l'année que la hausse dépasse les 1%
ce mouvement de hausse ne semble
d'ailleurs pas terminée puisque pour
tenir compte de l'augmentation du cours
du dollar avec lequel on paye le pétrole
l'essence pour la troisième fois depuis
le début de l'année aussi pourrait
augmenter dès samedi prochain de 7 à 8
ans 8 centimes on parle même de 10
centimes par litre au monde en raison de
ces différentes hausse le salaire
minimum le smic devrait passer c'est
encore au conditionnel de 13 francs 37
13 francs 66 de leur à partir du 1er mai
cinq voix seulement de majorité pour le
texte sur la participation adopté par
l'assemblée nationale et pourtant il
s'agissait bien sûr d'un texte
gouvernemental que le président de la
république lui-même avec
présenté aux français et bien cela n'a
pas empêché un tiers du groupe udf de se
prononcer contre le texte adapté
comporte trois points principaux
d'abord intéressement des salariés au
capital de l'entreprise participation
aux fruits de l'expansion de cette
entreprise enfin dernier point que nous
détaille patricia cause la participation
des cadres à la gestion de leur
entreprise les cadres administratifs
commerciaux ou techniques assimilées
les agents de maîtrise les ingénieurs
les chefs de service pour maintenant
participer au conseil d'administration
de leur entreprise ils auront un ou deux
sièges selon la taille de leur
entreprise et une ou deux voix
délibérative au même titre que les
autres administrateurs
ils seront élus par leurs pairs leur
mandat sera de deux ans renouvelable sol
imitation et non révocable par
l'assemblée générale des actionnaires
leur responsabilité personnelle n'est
pas engagée comme celle des autres
administrateurs
sauf en cas de faute lourde cette
participation est obligatoire dans les
entreprises de plus de 500 personnes
qu'ils aient un conseil d'administration
où un directoire avec comité de
surveillance
l'extension de la participation à
l'ensemble des salariés ouvriers et
employés en 1985 comme le rpr le
souhaitait a été amendée à la demande du
gouvernement qui réclamait la
suppression de cette disposition
oui ajoute simplement qu'à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui les communistes ont annoncé
qu'ils déposeraient au début du mois de
mai une proposition de loi en faveur
d'une politique globale de la famille
dont la première mesure serait une
augmentation immédiate du salaire
minimum et des allocations familiales
la police suisse arrêté deux douaniers
français c'est un peu l'histoire de
l'arroseur arrosé si vous voulez ces
deux douaniers enquêtait sur une grosse
affaire de trafic de devises entre la
france et la suisse
une affaire dans laquelle seraient au
conditionnel impliqué des personnalités
françaises dont ces fonctionnaires
auraient la liste c'est sur le
territoire suisse où il cherchait à se
renseigner auprès des banques qu'ils ont
été arrêtés par la police helvétique
le 14 avril dernier en vertu d'une loi
qui réprime la violation du secret de
secret bancaire si chère à nos voisins
suisses
voilà pour l'histoire résumée
philippe sassier d'abord qu est
exactement ce fameux secret bancaire les
suisses qui tiennent plus au secret
bancaire qu une rosière à sa vertu on
fait du mutisme des banquiers une
véritable institution nationale c'est
une loi qui protège ce secret bancaire
et qui prévoit la prison pour ceux qui
le trahissent ou cherchent à le percer
l'anonymat total est garanti et la base
du système bancaire suisse dans les
caves des banques helvétiques se sont
croisés les dépôts d israel iz allemand
fuyant le nazisme le trésor de guerre du
fln la fortune du shah d'iran mais aussi
l'argent de trafics divers et les dépôts
des épargnants craintifs certaines
familles ont installé leur fortune dans
un coffre fort suisse depuis plusieurs
générations et on estime qu'à genève et
à bâle que la moitié des clients des
banques sondées france on estime aussi à
environ 1000 milliards de nos francs de
nos francs à nous les capitaux suisses
et étrangers déposés dans ces banques
pour en savoir un peu plus les âmes
seconde financier de plusieurs pays
jouent à cache cache avec les autorités
helvétiques ont des français avaient
trouvé une astuce il relevé les numéros
des voitures stationnant un peu trop
souvent près d'une banque suisse
résultat l'automobiliste rentrer en
france avait la surprise de recevoir un
beau jour la visite des agents du fisc
mais les suisses ont à leur tour la
chasse aux curieux qui viennent d'opérer
sur leur territoire
il accuse carrément d'espionnage
économique ceux qui essaient de déranger
le boeuf que la loi suisse a mis sur la
langue des banquiers oui et déjà il faut
le dire un douanier avait eu un douanier
français avait eu un problème pour avoir
relevé des numéros de plaques
minéralogiques d'automobilistes faisant
l'aller-retour entre la france et la
suisse
mais pour en revenir à notre affaire
trois questions se posent est ce que ces
deux douaniers ans qu'était vraiment sur
un trafic de devises
est ce que comme l'affirment les
journaux suisses il possédait une liste
de personnalités françaises ce qui bien
sûr donnerais tu à cette affaire une
dimension supplémentaire
enfin sont ils tombés dans un guet-apens
ce que dément la police suisse ces trois
questions
philippe sassier les a posées à monsieur
jacques kopecky et directeur général des
douanes de liste
là il ne peut pas y en avoir puisque de
toute façon je ne sais pas pourquoi ils
ont été arrêtés ce territoire suisse et
de toute façon ils avaient dit qu'ils
allaient ce jour-là à bâle de bars et de
ce prêt des langues étaient non lembeye
par enquêtait sur contrôle des changes
cigarettes enfin trafic d'armes au cas
particulier de la presse suisse disent
privés qu'ils allaient enquêter sur le
contrôle des changes puisqu'on parle de
d'atteinte au secret bancaire donc c'est
possible qu'il soit allé à saint louis
pour cela pourquoi ils sont allés à bâle
parce qu'il ya un bureau de douane
française n'est pas là parce qu'ils sont
tombés dans une sorte de piège il a
enfin vraisemblablement parce que de
toute façon il n'avait pas aller en
territoire suisse il est certain qu'ils
sont allés au bureau de douane française
de balle venant de saint louis et de là
ils ont été attirés au buffet de la gare
puis c'est au buffet de la gare de dire
un territoire suisse qu'ils ont été
arrêtés avec un mandat d'arrêt qui
avaient été préparés auparavant par
conséquent c'est certainement un
traquenard dans lequel les douaniers
arrêtent ou interpelle beaucoup du
trafiquant de devises chaque année le
couteau sur cent cinquante mille
infractions douanières à peu près la
moitié sont des attractions de change ce
sont des infractions plus ou moins
importants dire parfois des infractions
bénignes effectivement de dépassement
des 5000 francs ou les 150 mille francs
pour l'investissement étranger puisque
savez toute façon il faut une
autorisation de la banque de france
au-delà de ces sommes là il arrive que
des gens en place en suisse de l'argent
qu'ils ont fait passer par des moyens
détournés
il ya peu près 75 mille infractions mais
avec des parfois les qui se termine par
des amendes de principe
monsieur andreï gromyko le ministre les
affaires étrangères soviétique a conféré
et déjeuner aujourd'hui avec le
président de la république monsieur
giscard d'estaing hier des premiers
entretiens avec monsieur jean françois
poncet avait été qualifiée de france qui
veut dire dans le langage diplomatique
que chacun était resté sur ses positions
sur le problème de l'afghanistan et de
ses conséquences sur les jeux olympiques
principalement et cet après midi à sa
sortie de l'elysée monsieur gromyko a
déclaré une nouvelle fois que le regain
de tensions entre l'est et l'ouest
n'était pas apportée au compte de son
prix
à travers ces serrures de la nive
l'union se lier et ferme se font
connaître que notre grand monsieur
mitterrand dans sa loge quant à la
distance pour la poursuite de la détente
aux besoins premiers liens que pour y
verser 6,8 et pour que les difficultés
qui choisissent une heure trente est
pour rien le terrain de la situation
internationale
oui ça serait rabotée comme notre côté
nous travaillons dans cette direction
pour acquis ce bien cela
neuf journalistes mais commençait tout
ne dépend pas de nous
nous exprimons espoir aux frontières de
la france
bouddhisme que le projet ira dans ce
sens voici bras merci
quelques minutes avant le début de ce
journal les entretiens de monsieur remis
au ministère français des affaires
étrangères cet après midi n'était pas
terminé mais ce qu'il avait dit à 3
heures de l'après midi en sortant de
l'elysée
ne laissez plus aucune illusion sur ce
bout et est le résultat des entretiens
seul en clair mais je crois que vous
voulez dire que l'urss ne se sent pas
coupable en afghanistan et donc qu'elle
n'a pas l'intention de changer de
politique
du côté français on ne s'attendait pas à
autre chose
l'intention était de faire répéter à
l'interlocuteur le plus élevé en grade
du côté soviétique
c'est le cas de monsieur gromyko que la
politique de la france à 3 change et
qu'elle considère que l'invasion de
l'afghanistan et les choses
inadmissibles point c'est tout avec
l'espoir que cela sera répétée au plus
haut niveau c'est à dire à monsieur
brejnev lui-même répété entendu et
espère port compris oui à propos des
jeux olympiques après la décision hier
des allemands de l'ouest de boycotter
moscou ce sont les chinois qui viennent
de décider officiellement de ne pas
participer à ces olympiades
l'iran continue elle son rapprochement
avec les pays de l'est après l'union
soviétique elle vient de signer un
accord économique avec l'allemagne de
l'est cette fois cela dit en iran une
nouvelle épreuve de force s'est engagée
entre les rebelles kurdes et le pouvoir
central avec semble-t-il des combats
d'une ampleur sans précédent depuis
trois jours au moins trouvent légalement
dans la capitale des errants ou hier de
violents affrontements ont opposé des
étudiants de gauche à des étudiants
religieux intégriste serge me serais
c'est la station qui hier à pire ces
hommes qui courent sont des esprits
c'est à dire des partisans de dieu
intégristes religieux qui donnent la
chasse des étudiants gauchistes à
l'intérieur du périmètre de l'université
cette université a dit l'ayatollah
khomeini qu'il faut purifier des
éléments trop pro occidentaux qui reste
depuis une semaine se déroulent ces
chasses à l'homme dans les universités
le bilan provisoire est de plusieurs
centaines de blessés et d'une douzaine
de tués parmi les équipes
c'est la première fois depuis le début
de la révolution iranienne que des
affrontements se produisent entre les
intégristes et les gauchistes dans un
premier temps il avait su s'entendre
pour rester unis pendant les mariages la
révolution tout semble donc indiquer
qu'on est passé maintenant à une
deuxième phase c'est à dire celle des
règlements de comptes entre religieux et
laïcs dans le dernier bastion reste
l'université un sondage sondage public
et ça pour paris match sur l'opinion des
français sur les problèmes du
moyen-orient
à la question vous sentez vous plutôt
proche des palestiniens ou des
israéliens 49% répondu qu'il n'avait pas
plus de préférence pour l'un ou l'autre
des camps à la question avez vous
l'impression que les accords de camp
david en cours de négociations vont
aboutir rapidement ou traîné en longueur
75% estiment qu'ils vont s'éterniser
les palestiniens doivent ils prendre
part aux négociations sur le
moyen-orient
oui de toute façon 34% s'ils
reconnaissent israël 37% et plus encore
si les plus durs du camp arabe menace
l'europe de ne plus vivre et de pétrole
par exemple si les négociations sur le
moyen-orient n'évoluent pas comme il le
souhaite et bien dans ce cas là pour 67%
des personnes interrogées
la france ne devrait pas céder au
chantage
monsieur alain peyrefitte ministre la
justice a reçu refusé de recevoir
aujourd'hui le comité de soutien qui
demandent la révision du procès de guy
mauvillain guy mauvillain ce nom ne vous
dit peut-être rien il s'agit d'un homme
condamné en 1975 par la cour d'assises
de saintes charente maritime pour avoir
agressé une femme de 76 ans morte
deux semaines plus tard de ses blessures
après avoir entre temps prononcé son nom
c'est sur ce simple propos d'une femme
mourant
qui n'était pas forcément d'ailleurs une
accusation que guy mauvillain a été
condamné à 18 ans de prison au terme
d'une instruction très rapide et au vu
d'un dossier qui paraît très très
incomplet paul de faire la ferme villa
n'est pas une conspiration de policiers
de magistrats malhonnête de gens mal
intentionnés
la ferme aux vilains et d'un dossier qui
pèse son poids de doute la ferme aux
vilains pose deux questions de fond dont
les réponses nous intéresse tous parce
que d'un matin chacun ou de se retrouver
à la place de guy mauvillain dans sa
cellule de la prison de muret première
question comment douze jurés peuvent-ils
condamné comme ils l'ont fait le 25
novembre 75 à saintes
peuvent-ils condamner un homme 18 ans de
réclusion criminelle
au vu d'un dossier qui laisse autant de
doutes pas de mobile pas de preuve pas
d'autopsié de la victime des témoins non
vérifié ces témoins essentiels écarté
etc
deuxième question la procédure de
révision d'un procès d'assises en france
demandent ce qu'on appelle un élément
nouveau c'est ce qu'on traduit
généralement par preuve d'innocence
n'est-il pas plus important plus normal
plus juste de prendre en considération
des éléments qui n'ont pas été présentés
mal présentés aux jurés et qu'ils
auraient sans nul doute du moins je le
pense fait se déterminer une autre
manière coupable ou innocent guy
mauvillain est le symbole finalement
d'un double blocage de notre justice
durant 18 jours mauvillain à y rester
chez lui libre alors que la femme qu'il
est censé avoir agressé pouvait à chaque
seconde
revenir à elle et le dénoncer ils
auraient pu s'enfuir
il n'a pas fait moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est qu'ils aient une sorte de
présomption d'innocence
monsieur giscard d'estaing ont inauguré
aujourd'hui le musée de la déportation
installée aux invalides à paris ce musée
commémorent à travers des photographies
des poèmes des tableaux et divers
documents d'une des pages sans doute les
plus dramatiques de l'histoire de la
france est dû l'opéra de pékin est
actuellement à paris les artistes
chinois n'y était pas venu depuis 15
mais attention l'opéra qui nous présente
n'a rien à voir avec celui que nous
connaissons en europe dans l'opéra
chinois
les chanteurs ne sont pas simplement
chanteurs comme nous le montre ce
reportage
le george lee
que les amateurs de verdi mozart ou
puccini ne s'attendent pas à retrouver
dans l'opéra de pékin les grandes
mélodies le déploiement des décors les
mouvements des choeurs auxquels ils sont
habitués
l'opéra de pékin et narre de très tôt il
raconte des histoires simples avec des
moyens simples quelques accessoires
seulement mais en revanche toute la
gamme de l'expression corporelle mime
danse acrobatie de l'expression vocale
et musicale et trouvent leur place un
art qui prend sa source au xiiième et
xivème siècle la légende et l'histoire
ils font bon ménage
les hommes et les animaux dialogue ça
semble se battent entre eux ou contre
les forces célestes
au fil des siècles geste maquillage mise
en scène ce sont codifiés et si tout ne
nous est pas accessible
ce langage a suffisamment d'éloquence
immédiate pour nous c'est l'une des
particularités de l'opéra de pékin et la
richesse des costumes c'est ici dans cet
atelier conte les fabriquent ils sont
ornés de broderies ou les dragon d'or
les poissons les oiseaux les fleurs de
légende se détache sur fond pourpre
émeraude ou turquoise
un atelier qui reprend vie depuis deux
ans après dix ans de sommeil pendant la
révolution culturelle
madame chan chin la femme de mao
responsable des théâtres avait supprimé
cette forme de fabrication l'opéra de
pékin ne jouait plus les thèmes
traditionnels car il était dans
l'héritage féodal elle avait instauré
une forme nouvelle de cet art une forme
nouvelle qui exaltait les héros de la
révolution en particulier le détachement
féminin rouge ou bien la fille aux
cheveux blancs et on est curieux de
constater aujourd'hui un phénomène
particulier car ces ouvriers ont un
certain bonheur a retrouvé ses costumes
ses costumes de leurs traditions ses
costumes de leur histoire ces costumes
de leurs rêves
à
et
les spectacles toujours s'inspire du
quotidien ce geste de femmes qui prépare
son aiguille et devient de l'art par
l'étude le travail
la stylisation savent en plus du mime
ans
une des explications les plus plausibles
de l'outrance des maquillages et sans
doute le fait qu'à l'origine les
spectacles se jouait en plein air il
était donc nécessaire d'accentuer les
prêts pour que les derniers spectateurs
puissent eux aussi voir les jeunes
physionomie chaque maquillage nécessite
deux heures de préparation toute la
psychologie du personnage doit être
perçue par le public dès la première
apparition en scène le rouge indique la
loyauté et la mesure le blanc c'est la
ruse le jaune l'intelligence le vert
l'esprit céleste malfaisant le noir la
droiture et l'honnêteté des définitions
que rimbaud qui donnait les couleurs aux
voyelles n'aurait pas désavoué
dans cet extrait du roi des singes le
roi des singes en jaune qui symbolise la
révolte des humbles contre les forces du
mal est aux prises avec la panthère rusé
féroce acquise aux oppresseurs
dans le choix qui nous est présenté au
palais des congrès on pourrait regretter
que la grande part soit réservé à des
scènes de batailles l'acrobatie ou deux
mimes ou encore de jonglage on n'a pas
le temps de s'installer vraiment dans le
développement d'une histoire mais il ne
faut pas bouder notre plaisir d'assister
à un échantillonnage de performance qui
touche à la perfection le tiercé pour
terminer pour gagner aujourd'hui il
fallait jouer dans l'ordre de 7 le 19 et
le 14 ce qui vous rapporte bloomberg
inscrit sur votre écran 2427 francs 50
dans l'ordre et dans un endroit
différent 4 185 francs 50 centimes voilà
pour la précision est maintenant la
météo avec notre spécialiste du jeudi
notre rendez vous habituels laurent
baumel écouter le temps ne devrait guère
changer dans les deux prochains jours
malheureusement pour ceux qui habitent
dans la moitié nord où il ya pas mal de
nuages
heureusement pour ceux qui sont dans le
sud où il ya plus de soleil en fait les
bleus baromètre est au plus haut sur
l'atlantique au plus bas au contraire à
l'est alors entre les deux villes c'est
cool de l'air venant du nord de l'air à
ses frais et froid même qui sera tout de
même un peu plus tiennent les jours
prochains des paquets de l'image de main
d'abord de la bretagne jusqu'aux
frontières de la belgique
ensuite d'autres pain dans l'est depuis
l'alsace la lorraine jusqu'au nord des
alpes en passant par le jura et les
vosges avec quelques averses et même
quelques averses de neige en montagne
vers 800 à 1000 mètres ailleurs ma foi
pas mal de soleil après la brume et des
nuages le matin principalement dans la
région méditerranéenne où il y aura
toujours un vent assez fort de nord est
puis également dans le sud ouest et le
centre samedi bien ma foi le même type
de temps devrait continuer dimanche ça
va se gâter dans la moitié nord si dans
le sud il y aura toujours du soleil dans
la moitié nord des vagues de plus
viendront du nord ouest et je pense que
la fin du week-end dans la moitié nord
sera un peu plus humide remercie laurent
même si ça n'est pas très gai pour les
jours qui viennent voilà notre dernier
rendez vous d'information ce soir ce
sera paul amar après le grand échiquier
de jacques chancel demain invités
d'antenne de midi alfred sauvy avec la
participation de jacques attali
l'économe
il emploie le chômage sont bien sûr au
centre de la discussion je n'ai plus
qu'à vous souhaiter maintenant une
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 bonsoir